puberty Bar Mitzvah Bat Mitzvah
quinceanera the commencement of
adulthood graduation ceremony and
literally a commencement you're gonna
get married you have a wedding you're
gonna have a birth you have a baby
shower you die this is Bali one of my
favorite places you die and you have a
funeral but between baby shower and
funeral nada
nothing why is that it is because in the
year 1900 longevity in the United States
was 47 years old and it was a lot less
than a lot of other places some midlife
as a premise didn't make sense
midlife was 24 years 25 years old or
something like that so the thing is 1965
is the year that midlife crisis as a
phrase or it was coined that phrase was
coined by psychologists and it is now 54
years later from the debate when we
coined that term and we've done very
little to solve it